Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
Thank you for listening.
We have an incredible guest
today and his name is Ed Catmull.
He's the cofounder of
Pixar Animation Studios,
which you started with Steve Jobs and
John Lasseter and president of Pixar
animation and Disney animation.
It has also received five academy awards
and as a computer scientist he has
contributed to many of the most important
developments in computer graphics.
He has done a hell of a lot and in this
episode we talk about many different
things.
The birth of Pixar,
his background going from a
technician to more of a manager,
president in this particular case,
the creative process, storytelling,
how they embrace it and developed it
within Pixar, the mistakes they've made,
what they've thrown out and much,
much more including the
lessons that he's learned,
the things he's observed working with
people like George Lucas and Steve Jobs.
Before we get to the interview,
two things that I like to provide.
The first as a quote,
and this is from Harry
Truman and it is as follows.
It is amazing what you can accomplish
if you do not care who gets the credit.
And in fact, Ronald Reagan has very,
very similar quote to this effect.
The next is a Japanese proverb. Of
course, you know, I'm a Japanophile.
I used to live there and I love
sharing Cotto Aza or Japanese proverbs.
And there are many,
we talked about the Saudi Milky got,
oh she did a few episodes back and
this time we have sheet on new shit.
A Nigga hot,
okay,
she'd on noon is not knowing
God as a subject marker.
Basically hotel can. So not knowing is
Buddha. What the hell does that mean?
She'd on new and got Hotel k means
ignorance is bliss or what you don't know
can't hurt you.
And the way that I interpreted this as
it applies to this particular episode,
is sometimes to do the incredible,
you have to go in somewhat naive.
And if you knew what you
were getting yourself into,
you probably wouldn't sign
up in the first place.
So beginner mind or being a novice or
jumping into the unknown can sometimes
allow you to do what you would
otherwise be told that is impossible.
Without further ado,
I want to get us to the interview.
If you want all the transcripts, the
links, the show notes and everything else,
please go to four hour workweek.com
forward slash podcast all spelled out for
our work week.com forward slash podcast
and if you'd like to support the show,
please go to my book club and you can
find a number of books that have changed
my life.
That's four hour work week.com forward
slash books hope you enjoy and thank you
for listening
at this altitude. I can flat out
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
Ed.
Thank you so much for joining me
today for a conversation. I hope.
I hope you enjoy it and I've been looking
forward to it for quite some time.
Oh my pleasure.
This is a somewhat of a landmark moment
for me because I feel like destiny has
had this in the cards. I remember 1995
very clearly for a lot of reasons,
but one of them was that I bought my
first ever share of stock and that was in
Pixar.
Uh,
and it was also I guess the
last year of Calvin and Hobbes.
So it was a very emotional year for me,
but I have been following Comic Book Art
Animation and Pixar for as long as I've
known of it.
And of course as as cofounder,
you've had a a key role in creating a
lot of the stories that I can pretty much
play back sort of frame by frame,
line by line.
And of course I'd like to talk about that,
but also creativity inc and
the book that you've put out,
which Forbes is said might just be
the best business book ever written,
which is a very strong testimonial.
What I'd love to ask you
is perhaps starting with a
defining moment and maybe it
wasn't a defining moment
when picks are went public,
what did that feel like?
Do you remember that day extremely
clearly or was it not a defining moment?
Well public,
which was in 1995 was actually very
close to a number of other events that
happened around the same time.
So I look at it as a period of time
and for me it was a pivotal year,
but we went public one week
after the movie came out.
Right.
Very smart.
So, uh, Steve Jobs, the
logic was that, well,
he wanted us to go public and he had
some reasons for which we were skeptical
off,
to be honest,
but he wanted to do it after the film
came out to demonstrate to people that in
fact in new art form was being born.
And that was right in investing in.
So the film came out,
it was a big success.
It was a success for me in the sense that
we had made a film and it wasn't just
a technical tour de force.
I never thought of this as we can
demonstrate technically we can do it,
but we actually wanted to make a real
honest to goodness complete film.
I'll just have that goal in mind.
And that's what we achieved.
It was also the culmination of
20 years of pursuing this dream.
So there is within the short period
of time, the culmination of 20 years,
the achieving of a goal going public.
Starting off on our next
film and the accident,
we began to think about two films,
the other being poor story to
having a relationship with Disney.
And while all this was going on,
hi personally felt a sense of loss.
And there was a curious one because
I had just achieved this goal.
The loss was in having achieved the goal.
I was now missing
one of the defining frameworks.
So I went through a period of a year of
trying to sort this out and I realized
as I went through that year that there
were some really exciting things observed
along the way.
And one of them that I observed was that
most successful companies have this arc
where they rise.
And then with that success,
most of them fail, fail quickly.
But a lot of them, they take longer.
But ultimately they fall apart.
And so the question was,
okay, how do you make it
so that it's sustainable?
Because the people that I knew
of who were in these companies,
and I had a lot of friends in silicon
valley or smart and they were creative and
they were hardworking.
So whatever the problem was there was
actually leading them astray was really
hard to see. And the implication
was that whatever that force was,
it would also apply to us at Pixar.
So this then became the interesting
question. These forces are at work,
can we find them before they do us in?
And so at the end of the earth that I
realized this is actually the next goal.
It's not a film if,
how do we have an environment in
which we can find an address problems.
So, so that was the big thing that I
got in the year at a personal level.
There was another one also,
which was not in the book,
but I will tell you about it because
it was a personal thing for me.
And that was when I was younger,
because I remember this thinking at some
point I want to be best in the world.
It's something, all right.
So this is a goal that I had.
So now it's 20 years later, the film
comes out and then I were successful.
And there are these phenomenal people
here. There are the technical people,
most of whom aren't well known.
But you've got Bill Reeve and Eben Osby,
he's liked out of that to help build
the technology. Uh, and besides, uh,
Jon laster and Steve Jobs,
there also is an understanding and Joe
ramped and Leon Creech and Pete docter
and a whole bunch of
people were a part of this.
So now being part of this group
that had achieved something,
there was a question that I asked myself,
which I did admit to anybody at
the time. And that was, well,
all of this work of us were part of this,
but how much of it was me?
Right? So this is this
background question. So, well,
I know I'm part of it
and I'm only part of it.
But how was critical was I to this,
and at the end of the year,
as the goal became clear,
I also realized that the question
was not a useful question.
And that in somehow trying to do that,
I was actually misleading myself.
Now,
the only reason I bring this up was that
I now recognize that a lot of people
when they reach that place
where they're successful,
they ask that question and
most people won't admit it,
but they do ask the question and a lot
of people reach the wrong conclusion.
Well, what I believe is
that what we did together,
it was not something that
I can separate myself from.
And this is true of most enterprises.
It's this desire to separate oneself out
is like asking for a clean answer to a
question when there is no clean answer.
And it is true of most of
the things in our lives,
whether it's personal or business,
is that the inner connection between them
and the way they're all mixed together
is inherently messy and confusing
and there aren't clear boundaries.
And the desire for complete
clarity actually leads one
away from addressing the
mess that's in the mill
trader on Wall Street is said it's better
to be roughly correct than precisely
wrong.
And it seems like that mess in the
middle is something that a lot of people
strive to avoid. You. The, an
incredible technical pedigree.
And of course we could talk about the
Arba Group. We could talk about, uh,
your work early on with all sorts
of technologies that then have,
have become standard technologies
in the use of animation,
texture mapping and so on.
One of my close friends actually,
who was a musician by training
ended up working at Pixar.
I believe he's still there because he
wrote his thesis at Princeton about
texture mapping of all
things and coded it himself.
But what I'd love to get your thoughts
on is as someone who's exceptionally well
trained in computer
science and engineering,
how did you take that precision of,
of thought,
that logical approach to problem solving
and replicating issues and so on, which,
which I find translates into
many different areas and
apply it to storytelling.
And what is in your,
in your current role and in previous
roles would have been your sort of key
observations with how to apply framework.
And I'll,
and just one more comment that related
to my, my one and only tour of Pixar.
I live in San Francisco and uh,
ended up having a friend of a friend who
was an engineer at Pixar besides rob,
my previous friend. And I was so
impressed by the process. I mean,
you do have processes and it doesn't
mean everything has a home run.
But I remember looking at
the color, sort of, uh, the,
the color coding of different
segments of the films.
And I had never observed it and it was,
it was so genius to me want to see it
laid out in front of me and that it was a
deliberate decision.
So
that's a mouthful that I just put out
there. But with an engineering mind,
what have you observed about storytelling
and why can't other companies get it
right so consistently or people
three or four things through
responded. There is one of those.
It has to do with the relationship between
the precision of the science and then
the r side for that.
I,
I go back to when I was growing up in
the 50s and a rather unique time and post
World War II,
but also a very safe time.
And as I was growing up,
my two people that I aspire to
follow with Walt Disney and,
and Albert Einstein, but for most of my
childhood, I want it to be an artist.
I wanted to be an animator and I studied
art and I did very well on arc in high
school and I also did
very well in physics.
But as I got to near the end of
high school and going into college,
I didn't see the path to get to the
level of what the animators were at at
Disney. So when I went to college,
I switched over into physics.
Now the interesting thing to me is that
over the years I've actually told that
anecdote to people when I've given talks,
how I said I switched over and I say
it rather abruptly like that when I was
talking to,
I switched over to physics and usually
there's a kid or in the audience
sort of like hello,
that's an incongruous statement.
Right?
But then that caused me to
think about it. It's like, okay,
why is that in Congress?
Because most people to this day think
of them as a so radically different from
each other. But I want to pause
it a different way to look at it.
And it comes from I think what is a
fundamental misunderstanding of art on the
part of most people.
Because I think of art as learning
to draw or it's an learning,
a certain kind of self expression.
But in fact what artists
do is they learn to see,
yeah,
the actual training is one of observation.
So now if you,
if you look at it from
that point I do is okay,
so which are the professions in
which observations, not important,
how about doctors or
they're scientists.
You want the skills of observing.
And for me there are different
ways of looking at things.
And if you look at the storytelling side,
then the first realization I think
I understood this fairly early on,
is that storytelling is
the way we communicate with
each other all the way from
when you're reading to your
children when they're young.
But it's also the news magazines and the
movies and television and storytelling
is a way we do things. But even
in higher, our good teachers,
the good teachers are telling us good
stories, their way of communicating,
understanding and what our scientists
and biologists and neuroscientists trying
to do.
They're trying to reach an understanding
and then they're trying to find ways of
communicating that
understanding to other people.
These are all different elements of the
way we communicate with each other. And,
and it's even stronger than most
people think. Because if you,
if you take something complicated
like making a movie as an example.
So you've got a few hundred people working
on a movie, like it can be toy story,
but it can be more recent films.
Well,
what is the story of the
making of the film? Well,
it turns out it's too complicated to tell.
Nobody writes that story down.
And if you wrote down all the complexities
of what it took to do any one of
these major complexities,
that fullstory is too boring.
It's too long.
So what do you do when you tell a story
but you edit it down and you simplify
it?
So you simplify in order to convey
certain of the ideas that are critical.
But you can't capture all of them.
So you end up with a kind of mythology
and mythology is a way of us teaching
basic principles to each other.
But then the theologies don't capture
everything and they never can.
So we are in a continual state of
trying to create our own mythologies.
And even when we come up with mythology,
like the things we did on toy story
to the people who are here at Pixar,
a lot of them weren't here
when we made towards story too.
So the pivotal experiences that are there,
which are part of our history,
we're not experienced by a lot
of the people who are here.
And you can't actually pass that on as
a story because then begins to take on,
you'd like,
it fades over time to a pithy essence.
But in along there's a personal thing.
So what you want is a new crisis
and in solving the new crisis,
which they experience,
then they get something different than
they can get by hearing about somebody
else's story.
So we have a combination
of both storytelling and
experiencing and we need both
organically appear in the making of
every movie or are they things that you
deliberately bring to a
head or manufacturer in some
way to galvanize the troops
and and spur creativity?
Well, I think in order
for them to be successful,
they essentially need to be organic.
So if you manufacture a crisis and
you can, is somewhat obviously,
because like you said it budget or
you set a schedule for instance,
and it's very difficult then to some
extent you are creating a crisis.
But even that's a little artificial
because the fact is if you don't meet the
schedule or can we meet the budget,
you have a different crisis, right?
So what you want are the kinds of crises
that arise out of the thing that you're
doing, but, but you don't
artificially generated.
So I don't think of setting a budget or
a schedule as an artificial generation
of a crisis.
But if we have a surprise that happens
because things never go according to plan,
then what you wanted to do was use the
problem that's there as a way of getting
you as a group.
The forced the change in the process or
is to figure out problems in order to
solve it.
And in doing so,
it becomes a combined joint effort to
move everybody forward and everybody has
ownership in it.
Joseph Campbell's hero's
journey or the hero.
Are there any other books or
resources besides your own? Of course,
which I would recommend everybody that
people can use to learn about mythology
or these sort of archetypal structures
to aid them in developing their own
ability to tell stories.
Are there any other books or resources
that come to mind as being particularly
outstanding?
Okay.
Or people,
yeah.
Yeah. It's fairly broad because I've been
influenced by so many people in so many
different things. I will say one thing
that I did, which was informative,
but in ways that are hard to articulate.
You came from this thing and
just my brain works differently.
It turns out I am unable to read poetry.
No kidding.
Because reading poetry within a
few seconds shuts my brain down.
Okay,
well it was just differences that
what I was actually describing this to
somebody, this is many
years ago. And they said,
well don't read it,
listen to it.
And then all this came about because there
was a new translation of the Iliad by
Thomas Fagles and it was in verse form.
So the thing is I couldn't read it.
So this woman at a dinner said,
well don't read it, listen to it.
So I bought the Cape and I listened to
it and I found that I was completely
enthralled with it.
And then I was surprised by the fact
that here's a story that was orally
transmitted 2,800 years ago in a
different language to a different culture.
And it was meant for oral
transmission of course,
cause they have kind of that rhythm to it.
But now translated all these
years later into English,
the fact that I have this oral nature to
it still worked and captivated me and I
was able to enjoy and pull in
this entire story. So that,
so that got me started down this path.
So what I did was I then started listening
to these lectures from the teaching
company and they have these
absolutely marvelous lecturers.
So what I did was I tried to listen
to lectures of all of human history.
So there's ancient Egypt and
Mesopotamia and Israel in China,
on India,
uh,
and going up through the Roman era,
through the dark ages,
the Middle Ages, the
renaissance. It took a few years.
So every day in the car
I would listen to this,
but I felt like I had this
grants sweep of history.
Now at some level it's all pretty high
level because it's listening to the
lectures and the car,
right?
But there was something about that which
gave me a sense which I loved and it
gave me a different feeling about
people and how things relate,
like to each other.
So that was one level of things.
The second is there are like the wisdom
books out of various traditions and
China and India and meditation and things
coming out of Greece and Israel and so
forth. And somehow reading all of those.
And the way people rest of those things,
which are the foundations of our culture.
I found informative.
The what type of,
you take all of those and say, okay,
there's something about a breath.
So I don't try to grab one of them.
I try to get some breadth there because
I do believe that we are better off if
we experience wide breath.
That's what a general education is.
And then there's some point
at which we dive really deep
and some of you will want to specialize.
Like I just want to do this,
I just want to be an artist so I
just want to be a scientist so forth.
So I understand that and there's an
experience of diving deep into something
which is indescribable.
So it's good to have that experience and
I think one has to breath that you need
a combination of the two and once you
experienced the depth in something,
you're actually in a better
position to go deeper into an area.
Once you've discovered
what your area of love is,
then there's the more monitoring in
terms of neuroscience and how we work.
And then the other is just the observation
of if you look at what took place in
in silicon valley and continues to
take place in Silicon Valley and in San
Francisco and the rise and the fall of
the companies and the way they interact
and the amazing things that happened
in the bad things can happen.
That human drama I find very interesting
and we're kind of in the middle of it.
Absolutely.
That's cool.
How do you look at the mess that we,
that we're in and the
good things that we're in?
Moved to the bay area,
up to San Francisco from the
peninsula was because of that,
that chaos chaos.
You mentioned specialization.
When you've obviously done a lot of
work with George Lucas and Steve Jobs,
do you view them as generalists,
specialists or both?
What were some of the key
habits or routines, rituals,
anything that either of them had
that that still stick in your memory?
Well,
what was particularly
interesting there is the,
while he was a successful filmmaker,
he,
even though he was not a technical person,
he viewed and believed whose core
the technology was going to change.
The art of filmmaking.
So with the success that
he had it with star wars,
he was willing to do something that was
not done anywhere else in the industry.
So he was the sole person
that did this and he said,
I'm going to invest in bringing
technology into filmmaking.
And so that meant not
only graphics and uh,
but also meant a digital audio
and video editing. So I'm not,
was fortunate to be connected
with George at that time,
but he was unique in this.
Why do you think he decided that?
Where it seemed to be lacking in
other people? What allowed him,
well,
I think the thing that triggered him,
and it's not that he ever told
me exactly what the trigger was,
but in the making of star wars,
it required the best use of the advanced
state of the art of special effects at
that time.
And there were two parts to that.
One was the precision control of optical
printing and blue screen matting.
So this is an optical process and required
a great deal of technical skill on
the part of the people who were there.
And the second thing,
which was a new idea for star wars,
but what's critical for effects
whenever appreciates this, but it was I,
one of the breakthroughs for the film
is that it's important to have objects
blurred in the direction of motion.
Oh, interesting. That makes perfect sense.
Okay. And if it doesn't happen because
of the way the projection systems work,
then I picks it up and we
actually see a double image,
but we're not conscious of it, but we're
conscious of it if something is wrong.
So what they did was they had a technical
group that moved the spaceships while
the shutter was open.
So they captured the blur on
the blue screen matting film,
and then with great precision work to
keep that blur of these space ships as
they then mad at the objects together.
So this was for the time,
very high level technical skill. And
then star wars is this enormous success.
And George realized that technical
expertise there was rot in by this amazing
group of people was one of the things
that helped elevate this cell and put it
into a different category. So
with asked success, he said, well,
let's keep going down this path.
How far can we go because of that world
outside there is continuing to change.
Now what's different about George was
he made that little leap or big leap.
Okay.
From saying technology was a
key part of this is saying, oh,
that world outside is still changing.
I'm going to be part of it and
try to incorporate it. All right.
So that was why he was that way. I don't
know. But he was the guy that did it.
Tuxedo park who was an amateur scientist,
but he took interest in radio and uh,
later had a huge impact on detecting
you votes and whatnot in the war itself.
Did George and Steve have anything
in common or much in common?
Well, I mean they were
quite different. I mean,
they're very different from each other.
Steve was an extraordinary person and
I wrote him about him at the end of the
book. But there, I allude
to him throughout the book.
But there was something there,
which I find a stressing because I
watched the arc of Steve over his life.
And the image of Steve that people know
publicly about the way he worked was
from when he was younger and I wouldn't,
some of those behaviors,
and a lot of them weren't
nice at that time,
but as a result of being cast out of
apple and starting next and then buying
Pixar from Lucas Salomon and
being part of starting up Pixar,
Steve who was so incredibly intelligent,
he actually,
he just figured out that some of those
things he did in the past didn't work and
he changed his behavior and he became a
more empathetic person and he changed in
the way that he dealt with them.
Now what the outside world sees is the
mythology of the young Steve and then
this,
all of a sudden this gigantic success
of apple and then the iPhone and they
connect the two together,
but they didn't realize the arc that
Steve went through. Why did they miss it?
And the reason they missed it was that
once Steve went through this change in
his life, when he figured
this out about 15 years ago,
then basically everybody that knew Steve
stayed with Steve for the rest of his
life. Right? So we all
witnessed that part of Steve.
He was always an intelligent
and incisive and what he did.
But his way of working
with people changed.
So when it came to the mythologizing
about Steve and would call me from since
then to talk about them all,
I was not going to psychoanalyze Steve
Ali was alive. Right? And nobody would.
So our boss,
our friends,
so Steve, my friend is, I mean at
the end, it wasn't actually my boss,
he was on the board of
directors at Disney,
but for all those years afterwards
that he still checking all the time and
talked and he had this passionate
interest and it was going on and he was a
caring person.
You know,
when I was in the hospital with my hips
being replaced and they were Steven
there visiting and checking up and
wanting to make sure that had the best
medical help.
And so that image of Steve was not
conveyed to people because the people that
knew about them viewed in,
there's just,
what's their private relationship
with Steve? So we talked about it,
right?
So the mythology about Steve was
actually a mixture of things when that
recognizing that as in,
as you're pointing out in Campbell's book,
there was this hero's journey, right?
And Steve went through that
journey and by the end of his life,
he was a very different person
than he wasn't the first.
What were the reasons for that?
People were skeptical of that. He had,
well, okay, so we're,
we're now making the first film and to
then become a public company for the rest
of us because none of us had ever been,
even in a public company,
let alone knowing what it means.
It's like this can be a major distraction.
And you guys stories about, well,
okay, what does Wall Street expect?
Does this actually kind of mislead you
into the wrong direction so you have the
wrong values in place?
So there was the view of what,
let's make some films and prove our worth
and get that under our belt before we
go public. But Steve had a
different logic. He said,
right now we have a three picture deal
with Disney and the financial terms of
the deal.
While they were as good as we could
have gotten under the circumstances,
once we're a successful company,
then our share of the profits
were actually pretty small.
So Steve wanted to renegotiate the deal,
although he had and always had a
very good relationship with Disney.
But Steve said at the end of three years,
if we then split off as a separate
company and we're no longer with Disney,
we will be their worst nightmare.
Yeah.
Have
they will have helped launch
a successful competitor.
So what will happen is that
when toy story comes out,
all of this is before it happens. So
we're, we're guessing about scams,
but this is Steve prognosticating because
he now believes that film's going to
be a big success. So he said what will
happen is as soon as the film is, is out,
that Michael Eisner, we'll realize
that he's helped create a competitor.
So he will want to renegotiate.
And if we renegotiate,
then what we want is to be 50 50 partners,
I should say right there.
That's a different Steve.
Then years before were years where Steve
of shot for the fences and try to get
almost everything for himself.
He now has reached the point we
said that's not a good place to be.
A good place to be is a 50 50 partnership.
So it's like a good standing
and it's a high road to pay.
But if we're 50 50 partners,
it also means that we have to
put up half the money. Well,
Pixar doesn't have any,
so we need a war chest.
So if we go public,
we will get a war chest.
Then when we would negotiate,
we can come in and go
for the kind of deal,
which is a 50 50 deal.
So the film came out and within
a few months it's the route,
the call from Mike saying, let's
renegotiate. And so c says,
okay,
we want it to be 50 50 and all of that
happened as Steve predicted it would.
And for me it was rather amazing.
Wow.
He's completely called it correctly and
it was coming from a place of the high
ground of a true partnership. That's
the way he wanted to think about it.
It's a more sustainable structure
all the years.
He ultimately had trouble with Eisner
but it's because he didn't think the eyes
and was I partner with him.
Well you know,
it had to do with certain things that I
was nervous said about in the public and
so forth and about Disney and so forth.
You just didn't feel like it was a partner
relationship you would expect and at
this time Steve had doubt,
place value on equitable partnerships
and there was a value he brought to the
table and in bringing that,
because it was a value was
actually when we could hang onto,
but he was always very careful to say
Disney itself as a corporation is one that
we really admire. They've done a
great job of marketing our films.
They've done a fantastic job
with the parks and so forth.
So through all of this,
he worked very hard to keep
a great relationship with
Disney because he believed
in the end that it was going
to lead to something good.
No guarantees.
Mc was always realistic about that.
But he believed that if we behave well
with them as partners, that would,
we would end up in the right place.
I think people would look at Steve or
they oftentimes we look at Pixar and say,
well my God, they're batting a thousand.
They've always gotten it right.
What I'd love to you
is sort of a two part,
it won't be one of my
eight parts questions,
but what was the hardest film for you
to make and why? And then secondly,
related to George Lucas. Uh, I've,
I've heard on numerous accounts that he
was hospitalized at least once during
the making of star wars with,
you know, and he was, I mean,
a really young guy at the time,
but it was just from overexertion
and panic attacks and whatnot.
That's at least what I've heard.
Which has been the hardest
for you to make and why?
And then do you think for a film
to truly be a landmark film,
that it is necessary for at least one
person to make a sacrifice of that
magnitude where they just are at the
brink of falling to pieces or not?
I wasn't here for star wars for whatever
was called the first star wars. In fact,
I never heard that. So I don't
know whether it was true or false.
I just didn't hear so I don't know.
But the bigger question is like,
which is the hardest?
They do vary in their hardness.
I would say there have been several,
which were extremely difficult
and some were only difficult.
Right?
I think originally we thought,
well, if you do SQL, it's
easier, but we send it out.
If you're going to do something original,
it's always hard.
Right. I would imagine more
difficult in some ways.
Yeah, because you have to take them
in a different place and you're,
you're constrained by the
certain world that you've got,
but you're expected to add something
in terms of that world that really is
interesting.
And not obvious.
So the only thing that makes a film hard
is if you keep going at it and it's not
working.
So you can't solve the problems.
And then what happens
is for all directors,
they are emotionally invested in their
films and they also get lost in them
having us, everybody, it
doesn't matter who they are,
whether they're new or
whether their experience.
And what we have found is that
since it happens to all of them,
what you want is this collection of
people, we call it the brain trust.
But essentially it's a group of colleagues
who have been through it to help
navigate when you're kind of lost in
this swirling mass because it's very
difficult.
And so the most difficult thing
is on the people themselves.
And we've had some films
where the original director
who had the idea got lost
in it and couldn't get out.
And so we had to make some changes
in order to get the film done.
So in our view, we've had
failures, but we basically,
we tried to keep the failures inside.
And it's not that they're
secret that we've had failures,
but we don't release the film that fails.
We will abandon it all.
We'll restart and we've had several
restarts. We just get a state,
it's not working. We have to do a major
rethink to get this to be where it is.
So we had to do that with toy story
and we had there the Ratatouille.
Wow. No kidding. I've seen Reddit's,
I've seen both of those
movies dozens of times.
At what point do you stop trying
to fix something and abandoned it?
Are there cases of total abandonment
and in which case or shelving something
permanently,
in which case,
how do you decide to go completely
scorched earth blank slate as opposed to
reworking something if that's been done,
I don't know.
Well usually there's a buildup to,
this says all of our films to begin with,
really rough
that people have is that a new film was
like the baby version of the final film
when in fact sometimes the final film
bears no relationship to what you started
off with. And what we found is
that first version always sucks.
And I don't mean this because I'm self
effacing or that were modest about it.
I immediate in the sense
that they really do, sorry,
the storyboarding level or what? How
is it appearing? What's the form?
Yeah,
you're going through phases of where
we come with the idea that you pitched.
The idea is you rework them.
Then you'll do a strep and
you have a script read,
have actors read through it and then you
go through a couple of versions of that
and then you start to storyboard of the
APP and you put it up and it isn't until
you get to, you know if Q versions
in that you begin to find,
okay, these elements of it are
sticking their holding. We, we've now,
I've got the tent poles for the
film that we can build around,
but it's a discovery process now and the
reason it takes long as you're trying
to do something that's new.
If we just want to throw up a story,
it turns out we know how to do that
really quickly and we know how to make it
quickly.
But it's not a good movie unless you
can try to find some way of touching
people's emotions are bringing
something new to the story.
So the reason we go out on field trips
and do an research trips is that we're
trying to take ourselves and our
directors into a place where they bring
something that they didn't know or in
the general audience wouldn't know.
And I mean I'll,
I'll use an example as ratatouille
where the filmmakers went to into the,
the three star restaurants in France
and the one to Thomas Keller's French
laundry and so forth. Now a lot of
people watching the cooking channel,
but the cooking channel is not
like a real, the inside of a real,
okay.
The thing is almost nobody has been
inside of a real high end restaurant,
so they don't actually know
what goes on inside there.
So when we take elements of the way they
work in the audience and we put them in
the Ratatouille as elements,
then the audience does know whether they
are true or not because they haven't
been there.
But they sense that it is.
So when you're watching
those people in that kitchen,
the way they're working in
and the way she's talking,
cause he was teaching him how to
cook, right? You have the sense like,
oh this is real and you,
you only get that by going out into the
world and finding something new and then
you bring that in. Then you have to
Meld it into a story and it's a long,
slow, painful process and involves
a lot of people and a lot of time.
So now the question is, or what
your question was like, you know,
what do you do if you abandoned it
or restart? How'd you do that? Okay.
In our history here,
we have only abandoned one film if the
other ones will either that evolved into
what they were or we did a restart
and the one that we abandon,
the only reason we
abandoned it is that we,
we realized we needed
to bring fresh blood in.
And so the person we brought in said,
yes, I will do a restart on the film,
but essentially we're restarting. I have
an idea, which I think is even better,
which is a completely different idea.
And when he pitched that idea, we said,
you're absolutely right.
That's a brilliant idea.
What movie?
This is the one that's
coming out next to him.
Okay.
So rather than being a restart,
it was say, okay, this is,
this is the film you're going to do.
So because we believe that
it was a brilliant idea,
but for the others it was a restart.
If you compare it with baseball,
like baseball has got this notion that
you got the starting pitcher and then
you've got through the really
version and you've got the finisher.
So you've got multiple pitchers
in the game. So there's an ideal.
And the ideal is that you'd
like to pitch the perfect game.
So one guy takes it all the way through
the game and finishes up other wind.
So that's the ideal. But the
ideal use, it rarely happens.
The concept which we accept is there
multiple people that do it. Not In film.
When we do something, we have someone
who starts it, but their idea,
which is to take all the way through.
If they don't take all the way through,
then they think of
themselves as having failed.
Right?
You step back and say,
you know they launched the idea,
they had a good idea,
they couldn't see any shit cause it's a
different kind of thing when you finish
and when you start
the value of the world is it frequently
you the value the first person and you
give high value to the second person.
But the reality is it's kind of all parked
together and you have to acknowledge
the fact that the contributions came from
a lot of people over a great length of
time. And it's what makes it
painful is it in this world,
if you have to make that change,
it's a personal thing that somebody
has and that's where the pain comes.
It's not the work.
Rapid fire questions.
Okay. That a very short form. You can
answer them as briefly as you'd like.
And uh,
the first of that is what is the book
you've given most often as a gift?
The books I've given most often.
I wouldn't say there is a single one.
Okay, got it. Is there any that you've
given more multiple times than others?
No,
I,
I would say there are certain children's
books which I've given out a few times.
One monster after another by Mercer Meyer.
That's terrific. I love that. Perfect.
What is your favorite documentary
or any favorite documentaries?
All the documentaries, you
know, he used to go to Sundance.
I love documentaries is,
or favor one though.
Honestly I can't remember
a favor one for me.
The documentary gives us a slice and
something we don't see. And so I actually,
I liked them as a class. I've
been so busy. The last couple
problem,
many recently.
Are there
any that stick out in your mind?
Well, for me personally, there
it is. They'll have a range
of things, similar video,
they're science oriented and so forth.
They've got them on economics
and on Shakespeare and so forth,
but the thing that had the greatest
impact on me was the set of them,
which was the whole
sweep of world history.
You have to take it like
section at a time to do it.
Although I must admit there was one which
was around the time of King Henry the
eighth there's that,
the tutors and the stewards.
I was so blown away with that
that as soon as I listened to it,
I listened to it again.
The tutors and the stewards,
that particular one,
I'll have to check that out.
There's a podcast that
only three months or so,
three to four months
called hardcore history,
and there's a series called the
wrath of the cons, which I highly,
highly recommend it. It might have
the same effect on you. When you think
hardcore,
hardcore, hardcore histories,
the podcast and there's a series,
there are four or five parts called the
wrath of the cons and it's about as it
turns out,
Genghis Khan as opposed to gang iskcon.
It's incredible and the delivery
read a book
thoroughly enjoyed
a covers.
It covers a number of different cons but
provides the pretext that the current,
I would say the then current
context and the delivery.
It's a synthesis from
many different sources,
but give the first episode Alyson and
I think that you will very quickly then
devour the entire series.
It's, it's amazing.
When you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind?
Oh,
and the way I view success is actually in,
in terms of people's happiness and so
there are people let others normally know
about that's the real success and
they were friends and so forth.
I think while they've achieved
this equanimity in life
and I just valued it that
a lot when they were sheep people,
do you meditate?
I do. I meditate between a half hour, an
hour a day and have for several years,
single session in the morning,
in the morning
or anything else.
I actually got started because of
visiting this involvement and center,
which is batten,
but in fact because I lived in Marina,
I live in San Francisco, we're
close to spirit rock, right?
Oh wonderful.
Become quite engaged with the community.
How to spirit rock,
which is of that particular style.
Fantastic.
What would it be?
Well,
I did your heart to ask because I view
myself as is constantly needing to
change.
Sure.
Others and looking at saying, okay,
well how can I do a better job?
So it's not like just one thing.
It's like,
oh well there are a whole bunch of
things where I would like to evolve or
improve and alter the view and,
and look at the world in different ways.
So for me it's not so much changing.
Something is can I take on a different
perspective so I understand or view
things I didn't see before.
A few pieces of advice to your 20 year
old self. What would that advice be?
Well,
it's a tough one because to some extent,
if I had told my 20 year old stuff a
lot of things that I know now just about
life, I don't know if I
would have understood it.
So I come to the position where,
because I think,
I mean the reason I wrote the book was
to try to explain things to people,
right?
20 years old.
But the way I view this or any other
book is that you read things or you learn
about them because you want to figure
out how to address issues and problems in
life.
But the danger is always that,
whether it's me or somebody else,
if we can look at these things as a way
of somehow sidestepping the problems and
there's a subtle distinction there and
not everybody knows what they're doing.
But I think advice is actually one of
like you always face towards the problem.
You actually can't avoid
the mess in the middle,
what you want or mechanisms to deal
with the mess. And in, in doing that,
you will end up in a better place and
you'll get experiences that you can't get
any other way than by experiencing them.
What,
what do you think the advice whether he
would have taken or not year old self
most would have needed
to here would have been?
Well, the reason it's hard is so much
enjoying my life and the people around it.
And I'm aware that if you make a change
and then the little minuscule changes
can actually send you down radically
different paths. And so I'll say,
well, okay, even if I've
made mistakes at the time,
right?
What I want to give myself advice,
which would have had me avoid that mistake
because then steak was part of who am
I am that made me where I am?
Right?
So I can look back and say, well, if
some of those things were painful,
I wish I hadn't done them
or done that or said that.
But it's not like I could say,
well,
avoid doing that because to some extent
going through the pain of making that
mistake helped ultimately.
Right.
Hard to go back and see, okay,
do something differently.
Unpredictable butterflies act
and what it could do to the rest.
Well this has been a lot of fun.
I really appreciate you making the time.
Where should people learn more about you
or what would you encourage them to go
check out? Of course I will
also put in the show notes,
links to the book and other resources.
But any, any parting thoughts?
I mean we've really touched on the
topics of course and when we've been 15
minutes on this for me,
all the issues of what it means to
engage with others and dealing with
uncertainty and how you address fear
and how you make safe environments are
critical ones and how you looked at
the world and perceive it. And, and uh,
our moral and ethical position in that
environment are all really important.
And I don't have any short way of saying
them, but to me they're important and,
and the help,
I get at least touched on a few of them
in the book and then talking about some
of our experiences as
we grew as a company.
And I want to make it clear
that we haven't figured it out,
the challenges in front of us,
every bit as big as they've always been.
Oh,
I can't wait to see what you guys produce
next and given how many mutual friends
we have, hopefully we'll at some point
bump into each other in the bay area,
but for now at least I will let you get
back to your day and thank you very much
for taking the time. Thank
you very much, Tim. Thanks.
Take care. All right, bye. Bye.
You want more of the Tim Ferriss show?
You can subscribe to the podcast
on iTunes or go to for our blog.com
where you'll find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and
Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park,
the books plus much, much more.
Follow Tim on twitter@twitter.com
slash t Ferris.
That's top Rrif or on Facebook
at facebook.com/tim Ferriss.
Until next time,
thanks for listening.